here we go here we go we got the story
here from CBS Don Lemon tries to pin
hurricane Ian on climate change without
evidence oh that's that's an excellent
headline from a CBS Outlet like
seriously it's a local level local yeah
well of course of course so let me let
me uh let me play this clip because it's
it's it's so can you tell us what this
is and what effective change has on this
phenomenon
we can come back and talk about climate
change at a later time I want to focus
on the here and now we think the rapid
intensification is probably almost done
there could be a little bit more
intensification as it's still over the
warm Waters of the uh Eastern Gulf of
Mexico but I don't think we're going to
get any more rapid intensification if
you look here you can actually see
pretty interesting for your viewers you
can actually see a second eyewall
forming around the inner eye wall and
that's basically the second eye wall has
overtaken the original variable and that
should arrest development uh so listen I
just I'm just trying to get that you
said you want to talk about climate
change but what what effect does climate
change have on this phenomenon that that
is happening now because it seems these
storms are intensifying that's the
question I don't think you can link
climate change to any one event on the
whole on the cumulative a climate change
may be making storms worse but to link
it to any one event
um I would caution against them okay
well listen I grew up there and these
storms are intensifying something is
causing you to intensify so this storm
is just it's a massive one it's a fact
trust the science they said as Don Lemon
goes I'm talking to a scientist but I
have personal anecdotal experience and I
think the storms are working how does
that fit into my talking point I have a
talking point in which you're saying
doesn't fit with it so can you take what
you're saying and fit it into my script
that I wrote for you what do you
recommend another scientist to speak to
because uh I'm not trusting you he's
like that guy's never coming back on
everyone I mean Don lemon's not really
known for his uh intelligence he he he
prophesied and theorized how a black
hole swallowed the Malaysian airplane
just a few years ago so so we're not
expecting much from him I'm not at least
that was funny when he did that and the
lady
I made a little video about it years ago
he's talking to this woman and he's like
you know a lot of people online are
saying that the plane may have been
swallowed by a black hole and I know
it's Preposterous but is it Preposterous
Mary and the moon goes or your rear your
plane is a small black hole which while
the whole universe gosh she actually
says a small black hole would swallow
the whole universe and it's just like
lady there's like a billion black holes
or whatever like that we can see no but
Snopes did a fact check on that and it's
actually it's true that small black hole
would actually yes no well Snopes did a
fact check so there's a super massive
black hole at the center of the Milky
Way galaxy as far as we as we believe
and uh Universe still exists so you know
whatever but that's Don Lemon and then
when I when I brought that up I've had
people defend them over that and they're
like well you know he's just trying to
do a show and I'm like what yo if I get
a couple of Stoners and sit him down and
they're sitting there with big bicycle
you know big twirly mustaches being like
dude what if a black hole ate a plane
I'd be like all right this is a good
show let's order some pizzas get some
sodas and just let it roll because this
is funny but when CNN the most trusted
name in news is is doing things like
that I gotta say you know like you know
maybe your brand ain't doll with a crack
was it what it's cracked up to be this
clip is amazing
because what did he try three times he's
like how does climate change play Royals
uh it doesn't and he goes well you know
but climate change and he's like no no
climate change well I live there so
climate change yeah I don't I don't
wanna I don't want to know about I don't
want to know about the hurricane I want
to know
why hurricanes are getting you know
bigger because of climate change why
can't you answer my question do we have
issues like this you know I know that
the liberal left Democrat types like
it's like fascism white supremacy
climate change they can easily just
shout anything like you know young kids
are getting sick and having heart
attacks must be climate change no no
doubt no I'm not kidding there are
articles talking about how there's an
increase in like heart attacks or
cardiac events and they're like we think
climate change is causing it and I'm
like whatever boss do we have anything
like that can I be like Don Lemon asking
this question as communism can I just
accuse everything everything's communism
yeah but at the and at the same time uh
remember the story it wasn't even a
direct Trump quote but there was a story
that Trump asked why we couldn't nuke a
hurricane like a hurricane and and
people got upset with him like oh my God
why would he do that it's like because
he wants to stop a hurricane I mean it's
not it's not like a nefarious thing it's
not like the the new nuclear bomb is
going to make the hurricane stronger you
know it's like he's trying to stop her
haven't you seen what is it the core
have you seen the core with uh Hillary I
watch a lot of questions
so they go down to the Center of the
Earth and then they have to detonate a
bunch of nukes in succession well so I
guess the plan was to drop a bunch of
nukes and then blow them all up so it
starts the course thing again like okay
hold on the core of the earth stops
spinning so like makes sense yeah the
planet's being destroyed because there's
no magnetosphere or whatever so they
have to like drill to the Center of the
Earth and then they like they find that
the mantle is actually Hollow or
something I know there's dinosaurs or
whatever there's no dinosaurs I'm
kidding but anyway they get to the core
and then they're like you know Land of
the Lost but anyway they get to the core
and they're like we gotta detonate these
nukes and then it will start the spin
again and keep the core going which will
generate the magnetic sphere whatever
and magnetosphere and then they find out
that they actually miscalculated this
the size they didn't realize the Earth
was Hollow so they don't don't have
enough nuclear power in the in the
WarHeads to actually you know spin the
core so what they do is they deploy them
in succession so it creates a ripple
effect so it goes one two three instead
of all at once and that's so so maybe
maybe Trump was not wrong you know a
single nuke won't do it but 12 nukes
could one two three four and then it
stops the spin from happening it's like
12 nukes could save one human life then
it's right they did the same thing when
he asked if uh we could drone strike uh
the cartels
and everyone was like what an idiot he
is asking if we can drone it's like well
we I mean I mean weddings in the Middle
East and
these guys are making drugs that are
killing our citizens and we can drone
strike a wedding in the Middle East
everyone will be silent but you know you
want to kill cartel members I think the
reality is that like if we nuke the
hurricane all that would do is make a
radioactive hurricane and it would be
like blowing radioactive particles
everywhere and it would just be that
much worse no I think you could deserve
that though for sure I think the media
would come out and go why would he want
to do that to that poor hurricane why
they would just spin it to say like you
know he's racist against hurricanes or
something oh yeah they'd be like is it a
natural phenomenon he clearly hates the
environment he just wants me yeah
he's sexist against Mother Nature well
Tim ruined my night because now I have
to go home and watch the core oh no no
you don't yes I do now I do yes I do and
who else is in it it's Hillary
it's an All-Star cast yeah and some I
think somebody died in a two like they
stayed down in Decor while yeah I can't
remember you know did Bruce Willis have
to stay back to save the world no no
that was the other one that was
Armageddon yeah but then there's also
wasn't there another movie that was
basically the same as the core because
they did Armageddon oh no it was Deep
Impact but that's the same time it came
out as details was the same as
Armageddon yes oh you're saying there's
another core yeah and I have to watch
both of them well yeah you can't watch
arm again without watching Deep Impact
Stanley Tucci uh Bruce Greenwood who uh
he was like the captain in Star Trek oh
uh the Star Trek movies yeah Stanley
Tucci uh sacrifices at least those were
original ideas in Hollywood you know
like they're like paramounts coming out
with one about the core now so we got to
come out with one yeah what's up with
that at least it was like original ideas
now it's just like they're remaking
remakes because the other Studios
remaking the other reason yo how many
Spiderman Spidermans do we have how many
Godzillas have there been like Godzilla
remakes it's ridiculous well cultural
stagnation man but at least Spider-Man
and that's She-Hulk She-Hulk though
beautifully it's a series oh but it
feels like it but it feels like a film I
must have only watched the first episode
no no no no look I'm a huge MCU fan I'm
a big fan of the MCU and She-Hulk is
some of the worst you just talked to NPC
ever seen I've ever seen look the i i
praised the first couple episodes like
that's entertaining like she's fighting
with the Hulk and they're talking about
superheroes and stuff the show now is
trying to be a lawyer comedy written by
people who know anything about lawyers
and it's just really really bad the last
episode was so bad that I was just
clicking skip every I'd like I'd click
10 second jump and then they'd be
nonsense in 10 seconds nonsense 10
seconds nonsense and then I was like
okay there was no episode here I'll tell
you when I like the show starts and she
and she looks at the camera and she goes
yes this episode is a self-contained
wedding episode and I was like okay next
it is some of the worst programs and I
have to watch both core movies and the
entire season of She-Hulk because the
worse it is the more I have to watch it
oh it's it's so bad
and they're dangling Daredevil in front
of everybody to convince people to watch
it that's the only thing they got oh
Daredevil oh because he's a lawyer
because right and he's going to be in
like episode eight or something don't
you ever like watching like a 200
million dollar piece of hot garbage
though and you're like wow here's what
we're doing
a new movie and it's about a guy uh
named Andrew who can uh has the powers
of an alpaca oh yeah it's alpaca Powers
sure and and it's going to be good
because you think about Spider-Man and
it's like one of the hottest Marvel
properties and it's the stupidest
concept for a superhero like if you if
you were like it's a guy who can throw
uh he can freeze things like okay it's a
guy who can throw Fireballs like I get
it it's a guy who is spider he can climb
walls and stuff I'd be like
well okay I guess so you know we grew up
with it so we think it's normal I think
that if I make alpaca man and you know
he's really strong and he's hairy and
you know he's like Sasquatch or
something and he makes sweaters from his
sheddings right well you know maybe but
like he spits on people I think can we
uh can we have a wolverine Cameo too can
we do that any and Wolverine's cheering
him is like to be polite with these
things
sweaters out of his hands all right okay
how about we do a better one it's a guy
and he uh he can uh no I like the alpaca
thing I'm taking it uh here's what I'm
saying I couldn't make I could make
alpaca man and with good story writing
it would work and it would be an
original idea we're culturally stagnant
we've got 87 Spider-Man movies 87 Marvel
movies and now like the whole MCU is
just vomiting up old stories from the
50s 60s 70s or just regurgitating all
the same characters again and again and
again it's like someone just makes
something new just
She-Hulk She-Hulk is not new Shield is
from the 70s you want to know why did
you not know that but but She-Hulk
hasn't been a property like yes it has
property there's multiple Comics there's
there's television show arcs bro
She-Hulk is a long X-Men on TV yes
really She-Hulk is a character that's
appeared on numerous shows in the Marvel
Universe I did not know that yes well
like into Comics obviously but on
cartoons I think she was in the X-Men
Saturday morning cartoon in the 90s and
stuff like that she She-Hulk is a
character that's been around for a long
time for decades and they're just saying
like let's pull up the old library of
things that have been made 50 60 years
ago and redo it and I'm just like bro I
would rather watch a guy who looks like
an alpaca fighting crime it's because
China is the biggest market for
Hollywood now and you know that like
Transformers Newton seven just goes off
the
charts because Fast and the Furious is
relatively a relatively new cultural
phenomenon I love fast The Fast and the
Furious universe is is the greatest
Cinematic Universe and you know they
went to outer space in the last time I
talked about this all the time and F9
they go to outer space in Hobbs and Shaw
they got a super soldier cybernetically
enhanced I'm saying an F10 I want to see
superpowers or maybe Mech suits
I saw a comedian I saw a comedian on
Tick Tock uh talk about uh he was like I
was watching one of the Fast and Furious
movies and and uh they introduced
Ludacris's character and he you know he
has a garage and then he had his side
hustle is that you know he organizes
these races right and then he goes I
hadn't really seen everything in the
series and I go to like I skipped like
to episode 9 or 10 and there's
ludicrousies like I'm hacking into the
Pentagon like where how did where did
that Arc come from like he was a guy in
a garage you know where the ark it all
changed I think it was Fast Five when
they're taking the plane off the The
Runway and it's like a 30-minute scene
and it takes 30 minutes for the plane to
take off and you're just like okay the
suspension of disbelief is like this has
been 30 minutes that they've been on
this Runway I mean it makes no sense
these movies are they're so over the top
and so ridiculous but there's this
there's just something about them that
that make them entertainers for F10 they
have Mech suits and ludicrous is like
you know Dom is like we got a problem
you know my brother is joined up with my
other brother and my sister and now
they're taking over the world and he's
like I don't know how we stop him and
Lucas is like I got you and he builds a
mech suit like an Iron Man suit and then
Dom is like he can fly and he's like you
know and then they all get Mexican suits
and then what happens is for f11 you
know he's wearing the new experimental
armor from ludicrous and while he's
fighting a group of terrorists there's
damage to the fusion core which which
blows up causing a chain reaction and
all the suits erupt but the energy from
the core gives them all superpowers and
now you know now he can actually he can
just run faster than his Dodge Charger
yeah now he's got super speed so it's
like you want to race and then he's like
gotta go fast and then what we do is we
started we start a pass button yeah we
gotta get Disney to buy Universal so we
can introduce them into the MCU and then
we'll have an original new thing over
okay how about this
we just start making movies that don't
suck we're doing it
I'm waiting I'm waiting for I'm waiting
for Trans Hulk okay that's good it's
gonna come and then the next few years
and there's going to be microaggressions
and they're gonna Hulk out and it's
gonna be awesome to see and I'm and I'm
waiting for that movie did you just miss
Checker me thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there